hey 42 here ghosts have been an
intrinsic part of the human experience
for as long as man has been killing over
debt and that's a bloody long time in
Homer's Odyssey and Iliad they are
described as a vapor gibbering and
whining into the earth interestingly in
Greek literature the ghosts or shades do
not interact with humans or the living
world in any way as people often report
they do so today though an annual feast
was held in ancient Greece to honor the
dead in which it is believed that the
spirits of the deceased attended for
just one day it wasn't until the
Victorian era when spiritualism became a
thing and people began to postulate that
perhaps spirits could reside on the
human plane and interact with a living
through mediums in Victorian London
seances became the alamode of society it
was fashionable for a gentleman or lady
to spend their Saturday evenings trying
to contact dead Aunt Edna though her
Victorian sails was infamously wrought
with deceitful tricks carried out by the
medium hosting the event it was common
for artfully concealed wires to be
attached to the seance table so that
when the spirit got a little agitated
the medium could took a string to rattle
a table about or even lift it slightly
into the air in England alone over the
past 25 years there have been over 1,000
reported incidents of a close encounter
with a ghost or demon remarkably this
number has increased when compared to
the preceding 25 years England is one of
the most apparently haunted countries in
the world and there are several notable
old houses and buildings where every
year numerous people report seeing
ghostly figures a cold shiver down their
spine and unexplained noises to name
just a couple the ancient RAM Inn in
Gloucestershire and ham house in
Richmond Hampton Court Palace is
supposedly haunted by the ghosts of
Henry the eighth and his youngest wife
Catherine Howard and blinking Hall in
Norfolk has haunted by the headless
ghost of an Berlin and there are of
course thousands of sightings or
experiences of ghosts mostly that
relatives
inside people's own homes all over the
world each year in America it is illegal
to sell a house without informing
potential buyers if you believe it to be
haunted but many people including myself
find all this very hard to believe and
think that all these ghost sightings are
no more than a load of old ectoplasm
which by the way is just egg whites so
what happens to reported ghost
interactions when they are put on the
scientific scrutiny the answer may send
shivers down your spine although it
probably won't there are obvious
explanations for minor paranormal
experiences for example creaking
floorboards are frequently caused by
changes in humidity levels and their
pressure changes can cause doors to slam
electronic devices can play up because
of condensation in the air or even
particles from outer space such as
neutrinos which can interfere with
circuitry but what about more visceral
experiences such as when people reports
actually seeing a face of wispy figure
standing directly in front of them in
the dead of the night well there are a
few scientific explanations that can
shed some rational light on most of
these supernatural shades bizarrely
ghost sightings can be caused by faulty
central heating toxicologists have warns
that exposure to carbon monoxide and
household pesticides can cause
hallucinations when carbon monoxide
enters your body it mixes with the
hemoglobin in your bloodstream which
prevents you from being able to deliver
blood to your vital organs this can kill
but before death sufferers will
experience dizziness confusion and
hallucinations there are numerous
reports of people seeing ghosts in their
homes only to later have their central
heating checked and discovered that they
had a carbon monoxide Allah
it's thoughts that's the rampant reports
of supernatural shades throughout the
Victorian era could be a result of the
heavy use of gas lamps and those carbon
monoxide poisoning was far more common
one should also bear in mind that toxic
poisoning is far more common in older
houses where ghost sightings are
typically reported because such
buildings have very poor ventilation
many people report seeing ghosts and
demons during their sleep
but many such cases can be attributed to
a particularly terrifying mental
phenomenon called sleep paralysis sleep
paralysis is when you suddenly wake up
in the middle of the night but you are
unable to move no matter how hard you
try your mind is wide awake but your
body is still asleep
around 10% of people will experience
sleep paralysis during their lifetime
and 5% of people suffer from it on a
regular basis most people who experience
a bout of sleep paralysis report feeling
fear dread and impending doom but they
also report disturbing hallucinations
that feel visceral and real at the time
many see demons standing at the foot of
that bed some people see ghostly figures
in the corner of the room sometimes
these apparitions even attack the
sufferer most commonly by strangulation
it's incredibly common for sufferers to
see members of their family or a friend
but their face is distorted and twisted
or even replaced with that of some
grotesque monster from the pits of hell
all this whilst the sufferer is unable
to move even their fingertips
and has to endure the horrendous episode
sleep paralysis has been reported and
documented all throughout history it's
believed to be the primary explanation
for many alien abduction stories and
sightings of ghosts during the night but
what about those spooky wake time
apparition
well perhaps it's all in the vibrations
in the 80s British engineer Vicki Tandy
was working in his research lab on his
own in the evenings he reported that
night after night he would have these
really unsettling feelings in the lab in
his own words I was sweating but cold
and the feeling of depression was
noticeable but there was also something
else it was as though something was in
the room with me he also reported seeing
spirits in his peripheral vision but
every time he turned around there was
nothing there
Tandy was spooked but as a scientist and
a paranormal skeptic he found his
experience hard to believe at face value
he investigated but couldn't discern any
rational explanation for the spooky
happenings until one day he was using a
vise in his lab to polish his fencing
foil as we all do from time to time he
noticed that even when clamped in a vise
are not touching it the foil was rapidly
vibrating he followed the vibrations and
found that the source was a recently
installed extractor fan right next to
the location where he had experienced
the ghostly sightings the extractor fan
was emitting ultrasound at 19 Hertz it
has always been well documented that
frequencies around this range can cause
feelings of fear depression and cold
shivers in humans evict Andy however was
the first person to discover that such
frequencies can also called paranormal
sensations this works because
frequencies that resonate below 20 Hertz
physically vibrate your eyeball which is
an odd thought and can cause your vision
to distort so if you see a ghost
perhaps check that your toaster isn't
malfunctioning but the depressingly
boring truth about most ghost sightings
is that the vast majority are probably
just another case of plain old peridot
have you ever popped your morning toast
out of the toaster to see the face of
Jesus Christ himself staring back at you
because if Jesus were to make a second
coming it would obviously be in the form
of a wheat based morning snack then you
have just experienced pareidolia the
tendency for people to see shapes
especially faces in random patterns and
objects for a long time it was forts
that pareidolia was a symptom of
psychosis but it has since been
recognized as an entirely normal human
tendency which almost everyone
experiences it's why we see faces in
clouds it's why we hear hidden messages
in music or random noise and is why you
saw Satan himself in your purge this
morning the human brain has evolved to
recognize faces extremely quickly
because by quickly identifying the face
and whether or not it seems welcoming or
angry humans can quickly determine
whether or not they should run away from
it we can identify whether or not an
object is or is not a face in a hundred
and thirty milliseconds on average far
quicker than how fast we can determine
that a tree is a tree our brain wants to
see faces everywhere it's why basic
character based emoticons such as a
colon and parenthesis are universally
recognized as a face
we even derive emotion from it the
byproduct of this neural superpower is
that humans very often identify random
patterns as faces and the world is full
of an almost infinite number of random
patterns therefore the likelihood of one
seeing a ghostly face in a piece of ward
or the ruffles of a curtain are
surprisingly high and then of course
there is the power of good old-fashioned
suggestion a well-known study in the 90s
concluded that the mere suggestion of a
place being haunted is enough to induce
sensations of poltergeist behavior 22
participants were led through an old
theater at night 11 were told it was
haunted and the other 11 were simply
told it was undergoing renovation those
who were told it was haunted before
and reported experiencing paranormal
events they heard more bumps in the
night creaking floorboards gusts of cold
air and mysterious shapes and faces in
the dark corners of the theater the over
11 participants experienced no such
happenings Joe Nickell is the world's
only full-time paranormal investigator
he has written 40 books debunking the
full spectrum of paranormal phenomena he
spends his life using a whole menagerie
of analytical techniques from toxicology
to blood spatter analysis to logically
investigate people's reports of
paranormal experiences and over several
decades and hundreds of cases Nikol says
he has never found one single case that
has ever provided a shred of real
evidence to validate the existence of
ghosts or any other supernatural
entities for that matter some
psychologists believe that our minds
manifest ghosts in our field of vision
after we lose a loved one as seeing
their face is comforting and aids the
grieving process which explains why so
many ghost operations are of loved ones
that we've lost if this is true then it
makes for a rather nice explanation to
an age-old phenomenon and a part of the
human experience that we may never fully
understand thank you for watching
I've recently launched my first book
which I'm crowdfunding fool and bound
publishing it's called stick a flag in
it a thousand years of bizarre history
from Britain and beyond if you want to
get your hands on a first edition signed
copy then head on over to unbound the
links in the description check out the
ones video over there if you haven't
already and pledge today thank you